who wrote candy oh gosh this guy named
jives something jive something you hide
something like I met him once in the
studio
remember this why are you laughing at
that song because why does it seem
ridiculous here what does it mean to
miss someone like candy what does that
mean kid I was like I don't know what
I'm singing about let s try it so I
wonder if other pop acts rejected this
song but they must have yep because they
must have been sorry because the song
became a hit I was a hit it wasn't like
you know it's enough of a hit that the
record company sends you out on tour
yeah with Backstreet Boys mm-hmm and
NSYNC and in sync that's Justin
Timberlake yeah you're backstage you're
a young girl you don't know what the
hell's going on he walks up to you does
he say to you you have very large feet
for a girl your age
somehow the I had backup dancers and
they had backup dancers and everyone was
sort of gathered backstage and they were
talking about feet or dancing or
something and and somehow the
conversation stopped and he looked down
at my feet and was like well you got big
feet for a girl and as a 15 year old
battle Rose like madly in love with him
right yeah
did those guys pay any attention like
could you have had a little thing going
with Justin Timberlake no I was a kid
nobody was looking at me like no one was
looking no no wow but uh but he did that
crush you know it did he's apologizing
though he's such a lovely guy it is not
me out he was like I just want you to
know that i reaiiy had no idea what I
was saying I was probably trying to
flirt with you and I understand how
words can have an impact that I was like
Justin sir yeah
Super Ball I'm fine